this
vtc was mostly about covet
and it has an enormous added value that
we have a
coordination to what our response to the
covet pandemic is concerned across the
eu
the tests of course were a big topic
the rapid antigen tests are good if you
have a high
prevalence of infected people of the
virus because there are so many
different on the market it is for us
important that we validate and therefore
we establish
a eu framework for the validation and
this of course brings then
mutual recognition across border
the vaccination topic was also of high
importance
we have now adopted five contracts
with biontech curvac astrazeneca j
johnson johnson and sanofi and we
continue
negotiations with moderna and we are in
talk
talks with novavax it was very good to
see
that all member states have signed up
to buy all the same vaccines and stay in
our
portfolio that is good news and we are
working on a vaccination campaign to
support member states in the
communication
on the importance of vaccines
it is self-protection and it is
solidarity